what's that belief nation that's Evan my
one word is believe and I believe in you
I believe in your potential and I want
to see that thing that you have inside
here come out and explode into the world
to make it a better place and so to help
you on your journey today we're gonna
learn how to be resilient and as always
guys as you watch it if you hear
something that really resonates with you
please leave it in the comments below
and put quotes around it so other people
can learn and be inspired and when you
write it down it's much more likely to
stick with yourself as well enjoy wasn't
so long ago that you know I was a
student and you know sitting in in a
seat in an auditorium like you guys are
here today listening to I remember very
specifically this time when Bill Gates
came to talk it at Harvard and I'm like
wow how do you how do you do that
and but you know the trick is is that
the media likes to sensationalize this
as if you have some Eureka moment or you
are some singular person who I can't
build something on your own and that's
just not how the world works you know
when I was in school I built a lot of
stuff that I just liked building there
was not a single moment when I when I
had some revelation that Facebook was
gonna be awesome
that's not maybe how the media or movies
or whatever would like to portray things
it's not it's much less exciting but the
reality is I think most I services in
the world that reach the scale that
Facebook has you start off building
something that you care about and you
know you don't necessarily think it's
gonna be that big I didn't you know I
built Facebook the first version of
Facebook for my college community
because I wanted to be able to connect
with
people at my school and I remember very
clearly talking to my friends at the
time and saying you know it's how cool
is it that we have built this community
for our school you know one day it's
gonna be awesome when somebody else
builds this for the world because
something like this needs to exist for
the world but it didn't even occur to me
that you know my friends and I might be
able to play a role in doing that
because we were college students right I
mean we didn't have any you know
engineers to work with or servers or
resources or anything like that and you
know there were these huge companies
that deliver products for hundreds of
millions of people right there's I
always assumed that it was gonna be like
Microsoft or Google or someone would
build this for the world and what
basically just happened is at each step
along the way we just kind of kept doing
the next thing and growing from there
and you know there were teams inside
these other companies that that thought
social media was important and we're
working on it but there were all these
different memes and narratives in the
world you know people would say oh well
you know this is just a fad people are
gonna use it but then they're gonna stop
so you know so a lot of the teams who
were working on didn't take it that
seriously or you know the higher ups and
those companies didn't care so then get
resources and we just kept going and
going and then people would say alright
well alright fine so maybe people are
using it but it's never gonna make any
money all right I mean social media
doesn't make any money then we just kind
of kept going and going and then pretty
soon we had a service that was bigger
than any of these other ones and that
kind of is how we are here where we are
there's no magic a lot of times I think
people just get afraid because you know
often your dream is its it seems like
it's so so far off but but if you just
kind of focus on building stuff that you
think is good and and you keep on going
at each step along the way and don't let
people deter you from that and you just
really care about what you're doing and
kind of don't give up but each step
along the way then you know I think
that's how you that's how you build
something good a lot of people kind of
mean they say well I want to be an
entrepreneur and I go that's great
what's your idea and they go well I
don't have one yet and I say well I
think you should go get a job as a
busboy or something until you find
something you're really passionate
about because it's a lot of work and I'm
convinced that about half of what
separates the successful entrepreneurs
from the non successful ones is pure
perseverance it is so hard you pour so
much your life into this thing there are
such rough moments in time that most
people give up I don't blame them it's
really tough and it consumes your life I
mean if you're if you've got a family
and you're in the early days of a
company it's I can't imagine how one
could do it I'm sure it's it's been done
but it's rough I mean because it's a
pretty much a you know an 18-hour day
job seven days a week for a while so
unless you have a lot of passion about
this you're gonna not survive you're
gonna give it up so you got to have an
idea of or a problem or a wrong that you
want to write that you're passionate
about
otherwise you're not going to have the
perseverance to stick it through and I
think that's half the battle right there
it's hard to remember how bad it was you
know in 1980s with IBM taking over the
world with the PC with Doss out there it
was it was far worse than the Apple -
they tried to copy the Apple - and
they'd done a pretty bad job and you
needed to know a lot and so things were
kind of slipping backwards and Macintosh
was you saw the 1984 commercial yeah put
that I hope you have that in your
archives
you know Macintosh was basically this
this relatively small company you know
in Cupertino California taking on the
Goliath IBM and saying wait a minute
your way is wrong this is not the way we
want computers to go this is not the
legacy we want to leave this is not what
we want our kids to be learning this is
wrong and we are going to show you the
right way to do it and here it is it's
called Macintosh and this is so much
better that it's gonna beat you and we
are gonna do it and that's what Apple
stood for but do you guys close to your
heart isn't in every single way and yet
it's a city in America that's going
through the one of the toughest times
and that must be kind of hard to man you
know grow the place where you grew up is
you know it's and it's in a bad place
it's in a bad way absolutely
but I think that it's the it's kind of
you know the Detroit mentality to to
we're kind of the underdog I felt like
we've always been the underdog and
that's kind of how you know I've always
taken that it kept that with me you know
I'm saying that that I want to say spite
the fighting spirit the Detroit has you
know because Detroit you know is so
resilient you know like like like I feel
like are like like people there we have
this you know kind of Detroit vs
everybody mentality because I feel like
people the the way that people look at
us they always count us out you know I'm
saying so I know that that attitude is
displayed a lot in my music but I think
that that's where it comes from is just
from you know just feeling like being
like we're being counted out and I was
is of utmost importance like I was such
a die-hard fan Laker fan growing up man
and just my personality like it was for
me to ask for a trade or to go play
someplace else to try to chase a
championship
that's not me man that's not being
that's not what my career has a bit
about that's not who I am and I stay
with it and stuff that I've been through
in my life you been through in my career
they just taught me anything is the fact
that you'll have good moments and bad
moments you have great moments you have
horrible moments you just keep going
through all of them and then things work
themselves out failing is never failing
it's always a learning experience
soldiers the thing about businesses is
how deep your pocket is I always say
that like if you got a lot of money you
could sustain these losses until they
turn into gains but if you have a short
paper if your money's not long if you
don't have enough you have to make sure
that those losses don't kill and
compromise your pocket and that's the
point you got to get creative but when
you do anything to get better at it the
more you do it and the first time you do
anything you usually don't do it correct
so it's not failure it's learning
experience if you would get up and it's
like in a fight the first round you
might get knocked out but by the last
round you get up in
like that person now one don't you might
lost around but you win the whole fight
but you got to lose some rounds in
business but at the end of the day you
got unanimous decision you got to keep
going you got to finish the fight the
question is do you have the stamina to
finish
I love the storm Colonel Sanders is one
of my favorite stories and examples to
give up an older entrepreneur this guy
didn't really start franchising his
business KFC until he was in his 60s and
didn't really become an icon or someone
super well-known until he was in his 70s
how many people quit too soon on their
business I can't tell you how many
people come up to me and say Evan I'm 25
years old is it too late to get started
like what are you talking about and
really just comes down to just your
belief system here was a guy who was 62
years old when he was franchising KFC
where a lot of people would be saying
I'm getting ready to retire I'm getting
ready to slow down I'm getting ready to
wind things up you know just ease into
the rest of my life I knew this a guy
who said no I'm gonna I'm gonna crush it
I'm just getting started I want to build
an empire right and this really comes
down to whether you believe it can
happen or it can happen you're right if
you believe at 62 years old that you're
too old to get started on something new
then you're right and you won't take
action but if you believe that age is
just a number and 62 means you've got
lots of experience and you're ready to
go crush some new project then you're
right as well and so you have to be
really careful to pay attention to the
story that you're telling yourself
because a lot of times we're holding
ourselves back with these excuses of
we're too old
we're too young we've come from the
wrong country we don't have the right
education you know the right parents on
and on and on and as long as you believe
that reinforcing story then it's going
to continue to perpetuate now in terms
of don't quitting there's a lot of icing
don't quit don't quit don't quit don't
quit you should not quit when it's your
dream when this is something that you
really really really really want to do
then you can't quit on it but if it's
something that you've lost the passion
for you don't feel energized by it
anymore
it feels like work to show up then
that's when you quit and some people ask
me should I quit this thing or not well
is it still your dream are you still
passionate about it are you still
excited about it because if you are then
you enjoy the process
and yes you want to get the results and
yes you want to win and yes you want to
make the money yes what I have that
impact but you still enjoy the process
I'd like making YouTube videos this is
fun for me it's enjoyable for me I'm
growing through it and even if I wasn't
on the path to hitting a million
subscribers I would still be doing it
because I love doing it and if I was on
the path that hit a million subscribers
and I stopped liking it then I would
leave I would sell it I would go do
something else because you cannot do
great things when you don't love what
you do and so as long as it's still your
passion as long as it's still your dream
you have to keep going or you're gonna
live the rest of your life from your
graph but you've lost that passion then
get out immediately and go do something
else that does bring you excitement joy
energy fulfillment Allen asks as we've
seen you hate wasting time but how do
you adjust on days nothing is going
right well there's no such thing luckily
no I mean there's no I mean I don't
remember a day where nothing went right
I mean first and foremost the way I
really deal with it if we want to get
Zen about this and a lot of you know
this is as long as everybody's healthy
everything went right I always quantify
when business doesn't go well I default
quickly to a business's bull it's all
about life you know like my kids look
how cute my kids are look how to thank
God my parents are alive like I quickly
switch from I don't dwell you know I'm
not good at dwelling I love speed and I
don't like wasting time dwelling
complaining wishing hoping you know
pondering how you wish it was is the
single biggest waste of time in life and
in business like the bottom line is we
all wish thinks I wish I was six foot
four the single best looking guy in the
world and the quarterback of the New
York Jets that has won 19 straight Super
Bowls I wish that I wish that I mean I
just wish that I wish that and and and
in the same way that that's funny is the
same way to wish that like that deal
went through or that employee took the
job or that person didn't quit or that
concept didn't work out I mean I've had
multiple divisions multiple strategies
here at wine at Wine Library at
vaynermedia that
haven't worked in the last 12 months
yeah we're dismantling it and so much
like anything else you just it's like
the next it's the next play using
artistic stuff like if you're doing a
Broadway play what are you gonna mess up
a line and just stop and just cry
onstage you just got to go to the next
line I mean just gotta keep moving
forward and so how do I handle it easily
I'm champ on this issue I'm a champion I
am an absolute champion on this issue
meaning like I'm prepared for the
punches in the face I'm expecting is not
to go well I it's kind of the way I prep
for Jets game Saturday night nobody
likes being around me because I'm just
devastated it's all bad we're gonna lose
this was gonna happen we lose well you
know like I I'm subconsciously like that
but unlike the Jets where I say that
outwardly these guys can tell you I'm
only on winning an offense at all times
you were sort of a Comics comic that the
people read yeah the comics like me well
know it's like being a writers writer
yeah the audience did not like me I can
tell you that they did not like me I
would be doing it I would hear that the
vile vicious comments that it's
unbelievable the disrespect it was it
was startling to see what people would
do with a couple of drinks in them what
they would call out what they would say
and I'm a sensitive vulnerable guy I
couldn't take it I couldn't stand it you
know so you know stuff like oh you're so
much funnier than him why don't you go
up you know talking to their friend or
you know and so um so it was rough it
was rough but there would be some some
really good ones interspersed with with
the awful ones but there were many many
awful ones I was working for a living I
operated restroom for about 25 years
yes trying to so be the best food that I
had served to the public that's where I
developed my chicken recipe that I
wanted to have the best chicken in my
restaurant than any competitor had so I
was on the highway where they go to
Florida at the Smoky Mountains
I was they went down to there I want to
get them as they come back and you'd
find out surprising how long as I forgot
all about the price of the food before
they could pull out the Koala that come
back again for that your food I was
listed on the nines and adventures are
good eating and I'd give me a very
select clientele to I had a moral
obligation to give people something good
something worthwhile see and I love it
now you come along surveyed this
interstate system that went seven mile
back of me let me Sutton high and dry I
was 66 years old I couldn't afford to
quit of course when they were talking
about it for three or four years before
look like it was gonna be a reality I've
begun to put on a guinea pig franchise
because I think of what can I do next
they're gonna wipe out this restaurant
and I thought well I tried to franchise
the chicken so by getting four or five
of these guinea pig franchises I proved
to myself that I had a product it would
take with the public profitable to the
restaurant man and also if we go was
just murder murder getting behind it and
kidding
put over for good so what did survey the
system I was left sitting high and dry
so that wiped me out
mmm isn't this a you know here's a case
where disaster really was a blessing
that's something that could have could
have destroyed you God turned it around
really I think sometimes people think
that you know you instead of laying down
and dying when the disaster comes you
can use it as stepping stone it's a
great home for something I would say no
question about that
so my question was what can I save all
of that wreck you see I'd really want to
be wrecked and the chicken was taken as
proving their taking with the public and
all I had to do to say wait and get it
going
I think tomorrow from my life is don't
quit at 65 maybe your boat hasn't come
in yet persevere nothing worthwhile is
easy no one loved achievement has
avoided failure sometimes catastrophic
failures but they keep at it they learn
from mistakes they don't quit you know
when I first arrived on this campus it
was we had little money fewer options
but it was here that I tried to find my
place in this world I knew I wanted to
make a difference but it was big how in
fact I'd go about it III but I wanted to
do my part to shape a better world so
even as I worked after graduation a few
unfulfilled jobs here in New York I will
not list them all even as I went from
motley apartment to motley apartment I
reached out and I started to write
letters to community organizations all
across the country and one day a small
group of churches on the south side of
Chicago answered offering me work with
people and neighborhoods hit hard by
steel mills that were shutting down and
and communities where jobs were dying
dying away the community had been
plagued by gang violence so as once I
arrived one the first things we tried to
do was to mobilize a meeting with
community leaders to deal with gangs and
then I'd worked for weeks on this
project we invited the police we made
phone calls we went to churches we
passed out flyers the night of the
meeting we arranged rows and rows of
chairs and anticipation of this crowd
and we waited and we waited and finally
a group of older folks walked into the
hall and they sat down and this little
old lady raised her hand and asked is
this where the bingo game is
it was a disaster nobody showed up my
first big community meeting nobody
showed up
and later the the volunteers I worked
with told me that's it we're quitting
they'd been doing this for two years
even before I had arrived they had
nothing to show for it and I'll be
honest I felt pretty discouraged as well
I didn't know what I was doing I thought
about quitting and as we were talking I
looked outside and I saw some young boys
playing in a vacant lot across the
street and they were just throwing rocks
up at a boarded building I had nothing
better to do late at night just throwing
rocks I said to the volunteers before
you quit answer one question what will
happen to those boys if you quit who
will fight for them if we don't who will
give them a fair shot if we leave and
one by one the volunteers decided not to
quit we went back to those neighborhoods
and we kept at it we registered new
voters and we set up after-school
programs and we fought for new jobs help
people live lives with some measure of
dignity and we sustained ourselves with
those small victories we didn't set the
world on fire some of those communities
are still very poor there's still a lot
of gangs out there but I believe that it
was those small victories that helped me
win the bigger victories of my last
three and a half years as president
thank you guys so much for watching I
hope you enjoyed I'd love to know what
did you think of this video what was the
message that stuck most true to you what
are you going to immediately apply
somehow to your life or to your business
please leave it down the comments below
I look forward to hearing what you have
to say I also want to give a quick shout
out to bite size lessons thank you so
much for picking up a copy of my book
your one word making that awesome
cartoon and posting it to Instagram I
really appreciate the support and I'm so
glad you enjoyed the read so thank you
guys again for watching I believe in you
I hope you continue to believe in
yourself and whatever your one word is
much love I'll see you soon if you had
to think of one word that's most
important to you or that sums you Apple
so it would be like a little beacon hey
believe nation if you want to know what
the most important one word is for Tony
Robbins Gary Vaynerchuk Oprah Winfrey
will.i.am and Howard Schultz I have a
very special secret video for you check
the description for details